yo what is up everybody it is procedure
mad luigi here with another borderlands
the pre-sequel video and we got a hot
fix so this video should be going coming
out on december 3rd yesterday december
2nd there was a hot fix applied to
borderlands zipper sequel that is an
update that you do not need to download
or that you don't see the download in it
just happens when you load up your game
and it's um
it changed a few things that i don't
think most people were expecting would
got would get changed in a
in the manner that gearbox or tk
australia whoever is working on the hot
fixes would change it
so the major points of this hotfix and
there weren't many points because it's a
hotfix it's a
semi small it's a small update
so moxie's probe uh got nerfed it does
less damage uh that's it's not too big a
deal it's like okay maybe they were
doing good damage i never use it so
can't really uh comment on that
old rosie got nerfed uh less damage
which i can be like
um i can kind of see how why they would
nerf it since uh
it is
the one of the
most used guns uh it seems to be in the
game because it's so powerful like it is
a gun everyone loves to use or most
people love to use so i'm i'm kind of
half and half on that update
um i'd say i don't know it was probably
considered overpowered but so yeah they
did that and lastly or the last major
thing
was that they nerfed the rate at which e
regira drops the thingy legendary
now you might be thinking hey a prestige
why would they do that if this game
already has a limited pool of
legendaries that you can
grow that you can farm bosses for are
we love to
get legendary from the grinder and we
kill yorjiwa and we get the thingies and
then we put the things in the grinder
and then we get legendary that's how we
get like all of our legendaries why
would they take that away from us and i
have no idea why also you can see the
this is post update and the rosie still
has a lot of damage so rosie
completely still you 100 usable don't
even worry about that
but
yeah so in a game that already has a not
super great uh end game and i went over
that in a video i put up recently about
the problems of borderlands zipper
sequel
the developers decided that it would be
a good idea to
take away more from it
now i'm not going to have this just be
one giant rant like and everything i've
seen about this has just been people
ranting so i'm not going to do that
but and i will say that i can understand
if say this say this was borderlands 2
since there's not a ton to complain
about in that game other than sal
uh say this is borderlands 2
and you had iwaji
and the grinder was in borderlands 2.
i would be i would say yes nerf iwajira
because
he does drop thingies too often for
how he should he shouldn't drop thingies
so often because their legendary's
legendary should be like that however
because of this game's end game
that was something that helped i don't
know save this game's end game because
it allowed people a method to get the
legendaries that can be argued to be
enjoyable it's better than just farming
uh
it's better than just farming vending
machines that is definitely that isn't
really isn't too much fun uh i would
rather farm a boss than form a vending
machine
so
it and he did drop it pretty often so i
can see that fix
in that sense of just thinking about oh
this boss is dropping his legendary too
often i would agree with that however
because of the circumstances of this
game and 2k australia and gearbox should
be aware of these circumstances
this was
i can't i can't see how this was a good
step forward
uh in this game
because it just
it takes away from the already little
end game that is present and the end
game of the borderlands is a huge part
of borderlands and what makes it the
game
it's stuff you do at the end that's
where you rack up the highest amount of
hours or where most um more dedi people
dedicated to playing this game a lot
will rack up a lot of their hours if
you're just playing it play the store
once twice then nah this really doesn't
affect you too much other than you might
not get a thingy when you go come kill
your jira
but yeah so that's gonna be basically it
um
yeah
good job 2k australia gearbox
like i if i don't know none of them are
going to see this video but i don't know
it's best just telling you guys i don't
think this was a good i don't think this
was a good patch
but let me know what you guys think
about this patch in the comments about
iwo ji or dropping thing is less um i
think it takes away from the end game
and it was not a good decision based on
the circumstances however i can kind of
understand why they did it so yeah hope
you did enjoy this quick little semi
rants i mean just hey there's an update
guys and uh check out the borderlands
content other than that i'll see you
guys later peace out